help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from timcast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
let's actually just jump to the story
okay so we have this uh from The Wall
Street Journal judge orders justice
department to release redacted affidavit
leading to search of Donald Trump's
Mar-A-Lago home I'll put it simply for
you guys the affidavit is mostly
redacted we don't we don't even know
half of the stuff in there is from the
sounds of it
Donald Trump was in communication Donald
Trump's people were in Communications
with the National Archives they said you
have stuff that you took from the White
House that's you know part of the
archives the boxes Trump had 15
contained newspaper clippings magazines
personal memos and some memos and some
classified information women's underwear
perhaps Donald Trump's people return to
those boxes
the FBI then said when they were told by
the National Archives they believed that
was probable cause that Donald Trump
still had more stuff in his house and
therefore they should rate him
they then found 11 stacks like packets
of documents and took them because they
were classified cash Patel mentioned the
president Declassified these things they
shouldn't have taken them it sounds like
they knew Trump had Crossfire hurricane
Russia gate documents that were going to
potentially implicate or at the very
least be smurch
the name of the FBI
and they need an excuse to go in check
or seize
this sounds dangerously corrupt and
dirty and uh
I don't I don't know I mean did Donald
Trump not have copies of whatever these
documents were as he's an old guy so
maybe but
I don't know if I believe there was any
reason that would warrant what they did
at Trump's house because he was
cooperating it already turned over these
these items yeah that's like if there
was a gun recall and they're like turn
in your guns and you turn in your gun
and then they're like hey that's
evidence that you might have more guns
we're going to see break in your house
and check like what no no no no no no I
I did what you asked I returned the item
maybe it had been a con if you're like
return your Contraband items if there's
like a drug recall return your cocaine
you you return it you get it rid of it
like there are societies where they're
like here dispense you're there then
they use that as a reason to go check
your that's Insanity no I just think
it's unrealistic to think any government
entity asks you to turn in something
like with like blinders on right they're
not they never granted anyone immunity
they asked him to turn in something and
it immediately gave them cause if you
turned in drug paraphernalia or guns
like of course then they're gonna be
like well we know you have a history of
owning drug paraphernalia or guns like
we're going to continue down this road
how about that completely fake story
about nuclear documents oh yeah The
Washington Post was like they were
looking for nuclear documents and then I
see all these leftists and they're like
Trump stole 300 nuclear documents and
the rights defending him and then it
turns out the warrant was just like we
would like all documents at any point
during your presidency that you may have
it's like okay well they're looking for
literally anything it's called a fishing
Expedition
they gave themselves a broad warrant to
take whatever they wanted it really does
sound like they're scared that those
documents from Crossfire hurricane will
get out now I have to wonder this why
didn't Trump just release them if that's
the case perhaps Trump Was preparing an
October surprise when he was announcing
he would be running for president and
then he would say boom here's the story
maybe I don't know I think it's also
notable like we talked about this a
little before but they didn't leak this
I mean Trump is the one who announced
the world that they were raiding his
house this was not leaked to the Press
beforehand I don't think the FBI wanted
anyone to know this is what they were
doing they wanted to turn off the
surveillance cameras and stuff I
remember yeah they wanted it to be they
wanted to have the element of surprise
and uh you know uh have have this happen
clandestinely until they had decided
what they had found to then tell you
about it and again Donald Trump kind of
interrupted that narrative by being like
no they're at my house like let's all
pay attention to this and everyone was
shocked by it I mean I don't think
anyone had a clear explanation I think
on the left there was a lot of
scrambling to come up with like a good
reason why why they would have done this
especially when they knew he wasn't
there that was one of the things that
bothered me that he was it was known
that he was in New Jersey because of a
golf tournament at the time they
specifically picked a time when he
wouldn't be there to do this the same
FBI team that oversaw the Russia
investigation
raids his house to take documents that
people are saying was from the Russia
investigation sounds like there's
corruption afoot yeah like they've been
on the track to start this to transition
to a new world order like you know
reduce I don't know what they're doing
with the American military bases but
just like from the liberal world order
to the New World Order and Donald Trump
was slowing it down and then so so
behind the scenes they're like we just
don't want him slowing us down but in
public they're like he's a villain so
hate him so that you don't elect him
again no I mean he probably he said he
was going to dismantle a lot of that
stuff anyway in the second term if he
ever got one or something like that
that's right I'm looking forward to it
there we were saying that desperation
leads to mistakes and there's no way we
can look at this aside from this was a
mistake
they're making moves that suggest that
if they didn't do it they would get
dismantled so we may as well do
something really crazy to try to save
ourselves because if we don't we're
going to lose anyway so there now there
are losing reputation by doing things
like this I think that they're if we
start being honest with ourselves and
each other that like yeah it's
inevitable man we're globalizing this
world is coming together in a new way
it's we're not going to be the King of
the Hill American is we're never
supposed to be like the top leader ever
and we're part of it well I'm okay with
America I mean I'm ignorant so when I
say this take it with a grain of salt
I'm okay with America just kind of
cooling it off a little bit let's focus
on ourselves getting it together here
for a little while before like it's like
that uh verse not to quote too many
things of like before you tell your
friend hey you've got a plank in your
eye or no take you've got a speck of
dust I've got a plank in my eye how
about America cleans its own up act up
before telling the rest of the world how
to you know operate themselves and if
the rest of the world wants to drive
themselves into a hole in a socialist
nightmare whatever the downside to that
is that we lose access to resources and
you know our advantage across the planet
but maybe we need to focus on ourselves
for a little while to clean up America
has been acting like you know as this
dude who's got a bunch of credit card
debt can't pay it off keeps taking out
more loans instead and then going around
and just yelling at the Neighbors about
how they got to pay up and give them
money yeah it's like me going to your
house and saying I don't like where your
furniture is let me start moving things
around but my house is a mess well I I
think you know just to be a little bit
more specific the US is just like
riddled with debt and then basically
just
printing money behind the scenes to
satiate its addictions while criticize
you know it's just they're either
assuming or consistent all right so
they're going to pass on that debt to
the Next Generation so maybe they're
assuming that the next generation is
going to do really good and we'll be
able to our kids will be able to pay
that bill that's the optimistic way
that's modern monetary theory is that
you print enough go into deficit and
that you are able to build enough
industry and infrastructure that the
product starts to outweigh the debt and
eventually you bypass the investiture is
that we haven't been investing in
Industry properly in the last 10 years
that's the lie that's what they want you
to think to make it make sense they want
you to think that no no look we're going
to take out we're going to deficit spend
I know you're right it's bad but we're
going to build these factories and it's
going to make up for it no they always
there always has to be more debt there
always has to be more debt to keep the
machine churning and all they do is it's
like it's a Ponzi scheme remember when
Obama did that stimulus where he just
basically gave people money it's like
all right everybody get free money then
they did it again they did with Cove
it's like everybody here more free money
now they're talking about how disposable
income is so high that people are not
working and I'm like are you kidding me
and now they're doing debt forgiveness
I look at the student debt forgiveness
stuff and I think it's in line with
their policy of just throwing money at
people
and I wonder why that is well I also
think it's part of their policy of we're
going to give you the good headlines
right but Joe Biden is going to be the I
left Afghanistan and canceled student
debt President but it's a sound bite
none of it is real I mean as you have
said before I I it's more than that they
gave free money unemployment they gave
free money bonus checks they they
deferred student loans and now they're
paying student loans they're they're
doing a whole bunch of things that
basically just distribute wealth
two other two to two people what's
monopoly money they're just yeah but
like
they're flooding the system yeah it's
going to cause hyperinflation and
destroy it it's it feels like it's on
purpose when they announced when Bud's
like I'm Gonna Cancel student debt it's
like after you already gave all of these
people free money for not working you
deferred their payments gave them
unemployment guarantees with bonuses on
top and they did not pay their debts oh
but they didn't have to now their debts
are kicking back in don't worry we
delayed another four months and we're
gonna pay down 10 grand of it it's like
why didn't they just use the money they
were getting for free to pay down what
they had to pay down
they just keep throwing money at people
and where's that money coming from your
pocket the Federal Reserve it's what's
happening is they're getting it from the
Federal Reserve and then so they'll
borrow a buck from the Federal Reserve
but then we owe a dollar and one cent
back so where does that one cent come
from Federal Reserve so now you owe
interest on the money you took out to
pay the interest that's the Ponzi scheme
tax money does go to the federal
government they do use your money and
then they deficit spend by borrowing
money and doing fractional Reserve money
creation stuff but a lot of the money
that's being distributed is literally
just your tax dollars that went to the
government so the funny thing is right
now
these leftists are like if you forgive
student loan debt you're just erasing
the debt from the books it's like you
are correct but that means the money
that we gave you our money is not coming
back you have taken our money from us
now I'm in favor of getting rid of the
interest rates and trying to alleviate
the student debt problem for sure but uh
taking money from the working class to
pay for the laptop class does not sound
like you know good policy it's they the
more steps that you have it obscures
what you're doing and it just confuses
people like if I read a headline I'll
just read the headline I'm not going to
really look into it deeply most people
are very low resolution when it comes to
reading the news or even understanding
the news I don't have time to read
deeply that's why I watched the news in
the first place I'll I want the quick uh
the quick story so I can quickly
understand what's going on and the more
steps they're doing it on purpose the
more steps are involved John Doe you
know going to work every day nine to
five he's exhausted he's got his kids
he's got his Hobbies he's tired all the
time he doesn't need to be thinking
about all this and some of them they
they package it in such a way that I'm
happy oh minimum wage is now 15 that's
great yeah but wait why is milk now five
dollars when it used to be two dollars
well let's never forget the inflation
reduction act I mean Joe Biden wants to
be the headline president where he's
giving you these like do you remember
all those good things
doesn't want anyone to look into it and
ultimately he is causing extreme damage
in his wake but he's gonna come around
and be like no no the Democrats are the
party of reducing inflation and like and
forgiving this is this is the one thing
that would make me want to run for
office is that if you're in Congress you
can come out there and be like I'm
proposing the help the small babies act
save the kitties and what does the bill
do it like takes twenty dollars from
every paycheck so that I can buy my
myself a house like just really
egregiously awful things it would be
like the bill just basically says Tim
pool gets 20 of every American's
paycheck and will be rich but it's
called like the save the dying children
act like why won't you vote for this
what's wrong with you there was a comic
and it's like the free beer app yeah you
see this one yeah it's like okay so when
do I get a free beer it's like what do
you mean free beer the free beer act
just raises your taxes by two percent
yeah well I call it low resolution
versus high resolution most people I
mean I'm stealing this from Peterson
sort of but most people don't have time
to in in graphics terms a high
resolution image takes more time to
render so cpu-wise if I have to read a
full page of text to understand what
this bill is versus just give me the
headline that's the low resolution
version what oh the problem with low
resolution is you lose all the details
well and when you see this with articles
it'll have the big headline that's
flashy it'll have the first couple lines
that have information but any any
information that sort of sways or gives
partisan like if if a publication wants
you to have a certain view on an issue
they put it in the top third of the
article because that's as bad as far as
you're going to read and all the Nuance
details are in the bottom too the bad
news is in the right anything that may
contradict their claims and that's
because they know that people won't read
that far they just I mean there's so
much media and so much information
coming out at all times right now it's
actually very difficult to stay well
informed on everything so I can't really
fault the general public for that but it
is how the human mind works right it's
the easiest way to sway someone but
they're playing they're playing the game
in such a way that like Democrats I'll
give them credit for this most people
don't have time to think about things
this deeply the average person you can
call them stupid but actually they're
just busy probably that's why with I
mean not to toot my own horn too much
but that's why Comics works so well is
because they say like you know a picture
is worth a thousand words let's say but
my Comics have four panels so the my one
thousand words yeah wow so it's like a
zip file I don't remember if I've told
said this before a comic is like a zip
file it's cross-referencing with like
hyperlinks that you already made you
might have read a story about this now
you're seeing four images that are
related to that story but now you're
thinking about other things that these
images are now recalling memories from
your memory and you're now filling in
the blanks so my four Images are now
giving you a full essay in the span of
five seconds maybe less that's why
images are so powerful and that's why
headlines are powerful and that's why
Twitter I've said this forever Twitter
is Comics yeah it's just every tweet is
like a panel you're scrolling you're
scrolling you're getting maybe an image
that's why I will often attach an image
to my tweets because it makes you stop
scrolling what's this image it's very
shocking to look at when I work for real
quick we pulled this uh this uh panel up
this comic from George comic we have
this comic hanging on our wall it's
right to the left of George actually you
can't see it but it's Joe Biden and he
says it is estimated that by that 200 it
is estimated that 200 million people
will die by the time I finish that talk
and that time is now and then he fires
Force lightning from his hands and just
electrocutes everyone in the in the
crowd it's hilarious and they're like
their eyes are glowing and there's
lightning everywhere this is like a
misspeak of Biden he literally said this
yeah he literally said he didn't say
this time is now but no I know but
that's the point like people who see
this are going to be like what's this
about yeah and then someone's gonna say
like that first panel is an actual quote
he was talking about covert deaths I
believe and he accidentally said 200
million when he met what 200 000 or no
no what he meant was he said it is
estimated what he meant to say was it is
estimated that by the time I finish this
talk there will be yeah no you're right
he was going to say by the time I finish
his talk x amount of people will have
died but it was like only 200 000 or
something it was a lower number but he
said 200 million he said will die not
will have died oh God
that's why it's important to have a good
editor I know right thanks for bringing
this up but I just love how he just the
the last panel of the guy screaming with
like he's like being electrocuted by
Biden's Force lightning so what we're
doing is as we're scrolling let's say I
see this in my Twitter nobody ever
thinks about this but it's what comics
wow I'm scrolling I'm scrolling I see
someone getting electrocuted I laugh I'm
now bypassing all the firewalls and
you're like uh I don't remember what the
frontal cortex I'm going straight to
your amygdala I'm going into your deep
brain you're laughing you don't even
know why yet now you're reading and now
you're downloading that zip file that I
gave you and it says Valor Margolis on
his uh
I don't know the neurology about
laughter and how it affects same with
crying and and fear if I go boo you're
not thinking oh I'm going to be scared
it's just a reflex this is this this
plays into what we were talking about
earlier with why you know we're doing
music we're trying like creating funny
relatable or entertaining spaces that's
what the Arts are this is what regular
people associate with this is what I was
explaining earlier on uh one of my
segments when I was shouting out the
song we did
when I used to do non-profit fundraising
if if you saw somebody like Ian in the
street and you walked up to him and went
excuse me search this moment of your
time and shook his hand and said I got a
proposal for you right now he'd be like
bro what what are you talking about you
got to walk up to someone like Ian and
go bro high five and be like listen here
bro you want to save the trees right
every day you gotta talk to you have to
you have to meet people where they are
relatable you can't walk up to a guy in
a suit looking like Ian and then being
like so brah you want to save some trees
get it back I'm busy I have no idea you
gotta walk up to the guy who's a
no-nonsense guy and be No Nonsense
listen I'll get five seconds we gotta
save trees I need you to pitch in you're
gonna do it check my hand buddy you you
have to meet people where they are to
the left you read it if you go to
someone with a moga hat on and a trump
flag and start saying listen you need to
understand Donald Trump Donald and Joe
Biden they're gonna be like I have no
idea who you are I don't know what
you're on about and I this is confusing
to me but if you approach them from
where they are you know you notice that
they've got like a Cubs hat you can be
like Cubs what up man you're from
Chicago and be like oh dude I got family
from Chicago meet them where they are
open a conversation and then find out
where you can you can come together and
you can share those important ideas
that's what art does people will see
this and whether you're political or not
it's funny Joe Biden's electrocuting a
bunch of people but it opens the door it
can stimulate things like empathy here's
a story that maybe you wouldn't have
been open to the message of the story
but I have told it in such a way that
now
you're oh yeah I do relate to those
characters I do feel bad for them or I
do feel what they're feeling and now I'm
starting to think the way they are I
relate to Joe Biden here wanting to use
Force lightning to vaporize 200 million
views coming out of him yeah I saw that
I was like I know exactly how you feel
Joe me too I do almost spoken I think we
have this illusion that people are more
politically engaged because politics has
seeped into so much of our culture it's
in our pop it's in our popular culture
it's uh bled into art we we hear about a
lot and I think that's true even of
people who don't work in my field uh but
actually most people aren't that
interested they do like Comics they like
things that are more accessible to them
so I think you're totally right that
having something if I if I were to send
someone a CNN Headline or a Fox news
headline you know they might already
have their guard up whereas art or
something that they're interested in a
on a medium that they're already
scrolling through Twitter is much more
accessible and also more enjoyable
because they don't feel like they're
going to be immediately sorted into some
sort of category well the news a lot of
the time is very dry and I I just don't
want to download all this information
but if I'm online scrolling maybe I'm on
the toilet or something I'm on the bus I
just want to be entertained I want to
laugh I want to smile I want to see
something interesting I want to be
entertained when I'm on the toilet
that's right you know I used to have
this thing called bathroom readers that
were like at my house and they're just
books full of Random trivia yeah that
you're like you're supposed to read when
you're taking a dump yeah I got one of
my bathroom says what uh what is your
poo telling you is the name of the book
okay well that's not what I was doing
the book I read was just like it was
called the bathroom reader and it had on
the bottom of every page a factoid and
then it had chapters of like random
stories and legends and facts and it
just filled my brain up with random
nonsense is that why you know the name
of that law
that's a journalism thing you know I
hate I I despise the corporate press so
much that I've liked it yes how can I
criticize them today what do you guys
think about removing titles from bills
just having them numbered I think we get
too confusing I think Bills should be
chopped up into the individual things
that they're trying to pass and not
turned into omnibuses yeah yeah the uh
Confederates said that didn't they did
yeah this is actually really interesting
they had something that said something
like it has to be a really short summary
one page something like this one issue
can it just one issue exactly but then
what they know they can't uh inject all
their stupid crap in there because you
could even with one section of a bill
you could still call it the Happy Lucky
Bill and then all about people give me
100 bucks it's a bill called like the
saving Ian and helping him live a happy
life bill but the Bill calls for the
imprisonment for me to chop wood all day
yeah I like to be in prison and that's
like well because we think that'll be
good for him yeah yeah you think you're
helping I don't like the names they're
very manipulative all the Patriot Act
come on oh yeah it's garbage and people
fall for it there was one more thing I
wanted to add on that subject too is the
fact that the left has annexed all of
the Arts it was not an accident they
know that people are bored of news the
only way to it's like Inception to give
you the thoughts that I want to give you
I'm going to tell you a story or a
parable so they will spend millions and
bazillions of dollars uh creating movies
writing stories uh songs anything
related to the Arts and that's why
they've taken over all of the Arts I'm
not joking they've taken over all of the
Arts because that's how you can persuade
people without even they don't even know
it and they know that it's much harder
to convince someone who does know to
invest in those spaces what do you see
across the board among those who are
aware of what's going on everything they
do is political this is what frustrates
me we get a bunch of really great songs
and and I'm saying bad you know the top
ranking songs overtly political fjb like
three different fjb songs reached up
okay that's still a net positive because
regular people will see like how come
the top songs are fjb but they're not
going to convince most people it does
create some awareness people who are
aware red pill whatever to call it
you're it's harder to convince them to
say like hey subscribe to a a a
children's channel that's like family
education content because they're going
to be like how is this engaging in in
the battle to to fight against these
ideas because it seems counter-intuitive
but it's exactly what the left has been
doing to the tune of hundreds of
billions of dollars for decades maybe a
century over a century I mean they did
it to Hollywood they're doing it with
music I mean when we were kids they were
always talking in church about oh all
this music's all about sex all the time
but we are now seeing what happens when
cultures hyper-sexualizing young people
let's say we're seeing what happens when
that is unchecked we don't know like I
love manga for instance if I go to the
manga section like a lot of young people
love it and stuff but those stories are
actually a lot of them can be pretty
raunchy and like super rated you know ex
and stuff like that I could go to a
local library I was telling a young
person in my life hey you should go to
the library and read these mangas but
definitely don't read these ones I can't
stop them from doing that but when they
have access to entertainment that is
let's say let's say there's an agenda to
push certain subjects on young people
especially because when they grow up
they will be more permissive towards
these subjects
the parents don't even know what these
kids have access to no they don't I also
think the art used to be a polite way
like impolite culture you wouldn't
discuss politics or anything too
controversial so you talk about art you
talk about what's going on and that was
an easy way for certain ideologies to
Route into daily conversations they can
just jumped around it and because things
are more blurred and because we have so
many
um you know I'm thinking like
celebrities who come out with these big
public statements about their political
beliefs uh it's actually not the perfect
Escape Route it once was and I think
it's waking conservatives up to the fact
that like they abandoned this space
before they even knew they could use it
I mean what's the what was the number
one song right now you looked it up oh
yeah I have it pulled up
um only ever wanted I believe oh we wish
we wish a super freaky girl by Nicki
Minaj okay I wonder what that's about
honestly I don't know but it sounds like
looking pretty sexy in that picture
remember when Ben Shapiro wrapped that
famous song white ass [ __ ] yeah and it
actually was really funny because he
like read the lyrics and then someone
took him reading and put it on the song
actually really funny yeah but um
do you wonder why it is that when you
look at the tops like the top tracks so
often the songs are like not appropriate
for kids or that you actually have some
artists that gloat and laugh at the idea
that your kids listen to the horrible
things they're talking about in this
music
dude don't ask me why but the right
abandoned this space a long time ago and
it probably has something to do with
telling telling kids like you don't want
to be a musician that's a waste of a
career like you need to grow up and be a
doctor or run a business they don't
think that art the Arts and I've been
trying to convince them for the longest
time the Arts are not a good investment
they might say but there's that saying
of uh politics are Downstream from
culture when most young people who have
more time than anybody else to consume
Media or anything like that watch movies
anything music they have access to
anything that you want to put into their
brains without any supervision
whatsoever
yeah I think conservatives Ensemble 2 uh
reward seriousness or what they perceive
as seriousness and so often when you're
interested in creative activities it's
like well now she can prove to me that
you can make money off this right away
you know it's it's a it's something you
do on the side and you enjoying the fun
whereas like uh you know a credit to my
friends who grew up in really liberal
households their parents when they were
passionate about something did take
basically everything seriously uh and
you know there are pros and cons to both
approaches but I think that leaves the
door open to people feeling like your
art is incredibly important you have to
pursue it to to the point where it
becomes influential whereas you know
often the other the other approach is to
say like wait until you have the funds
to finance your life as an artist when I
was younger the the Liberals in where I
grew up were basically saying you can do
whatever you want to do dream dream big
you can you know you want to be an actor
you want to play video games whatever it
is you want to do the conservatives in
my life were much more like just work
hard get a good job and make money and
there's no fun in there but you get a
lot of people so I know I I there are
people that I knew that were very much
into the Arts when they were younger but
they had very conservative parents you
know I went to Catholic school for a
little bit and where are they now they
have family they have some kids and and
really it really I'm sure they're very
happy good for them I'm I'm glad that
they're you know they're leading a good
life and they're doing right by their
kids but this also means that many of
these kids did not pursue the Arts that
they were involved in and thus the
people who did and why is it they all do
drugs all the time where is it you know
that where are the rock stars who are
just like oh man I'm sober I don't want
to do any of that stuff I'm just about
living a good life and being doing right
by my friends and family in my community
sure that's like a rare thing to hear in
like celebrity culture in Hollywood
they're doing drugs they're like
you know just raunchy you get it yeah
have you ever seen the sorry uh have you
ever seen the documentary the other f
word it's about these punk rockers who
like become fathers and kind of what
their experience is it's it's really
good uh and a lot of them talk about
there's one in particular who talks
about like being on tour all the time
and like partying and the culture that
comes with that and he's like but the
thing is like when you have kids like
you may be up until 4 a.m do drugs doing
whatever but like your baby's gonna be
up at six and you you have to get up
with it and so it's a shift in mindset
and I think that uh it is one of the
challenges of being an artist or you
know a lot of careers have this but like
you have to sacrifice when you have
other demands in your life and I think a
lot of especially popular left-leaning
artists now don't have those kind of
responsibilities because they defer
becoming parents and so they can
continue to pursue this path and push
the ideology I I want to say the right
is learning but I don't know if that's
the really what's happening I think
what's happening is there are are
liberals who are joining the right
that people who are used to be into the
Arts and fairly left-leaning who are
either forced out or who who saw how
crazy the left was getting and moved out
so there there's um this this movie
coming out my son Hunter
is my son Hunter I think it's called and
um the dude who put it together I think
he's the guy from Goonies right
sure that's what you told me Robert
Davey yeah that's all I know is what you
told me yeah so I'm thinking what's
happening is that there are people who
had the skills and know how to make this
content start realizing how crazy things
are getting and are bringing that art
and culture to the right and the right
needs to support and embrace it like
like the daily wire they get it they've
repeatedly said that we're not making
political stuff we're just making shows
and movies and they're buying movies
because they get it I think Jeremy all
those guys man Mike Michael Jeremy
um they're an example of like
perceptive tolerance uh I'm not on the
left I mean I was like I guess you say I
left this I was a liberal like wacky
zany artist my whole life and I just
left because it was like don't tell me I
have white privilege you know you got to
use better words than that if you want
to communicate with me but I'm not going
to be sitting told that I'm a I'm an
evil I'm a demon I'm not living that way
uh so I disassociated from those people
but people like Jeremy doesn't give like
he just listen loves people you know he
just likes cool people they hired a
Disney executive yeah to be their Chief
marketing officer that means that this
Disney executive now reports to a man
who goes to church on Sunday best hating
that's seriously taken over the space
and taken it away from them so I hope
they can continue to grow and expand
because the daily wire really needs
those Smart TV apps I know we do too but
I can just say like with the amount of
resources they have
you know they're going to get there
before we do but we've been having a
bunch of meetings about getting our
mobile apps and our TV apps so that you
can watch what shows we have uh as soon
as possible you know on your TV I'm glad
you brought up thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there